welcome back to another episode of from
the point by your favorite Point
presented by Sprite winter spice
cranberry and we also as you can see by
the Mike got a new partner brand um that
we Al like showing the show on um
Bleacher Report um thank y'all um for
obviously allowing us to be a part of
the brand and uh appreciate y'all
wanting to be a part of our brand so
appreciate everybody all right you got
my boy Winston
again you good my brother what up guys
um I'm all good man uh super exciting
man we're so thankful for Bleacher
Report this is a this a super exciting
partnership we're we're really excited
to bring you guys some of the stuff
we've been working on um but yeah we're
we're we're we're ready to go we're
ready to dive into it um you know Trey I
know I know it's been a while since we
recorded uh last episode dropped with
Lou Williams but um congratulations bro
uh on the birth of your second second
child teal Dove data too now man what's
what's it like having all them kids in a
house all them kids it's not it's not
crazy amount right now uh who knows how
many I'll eventually have but uh I mean
it's a blessing bro I mean having Titus
was I mean an unreal blessing um but now
having teal it's it's even another
special blessing I mean I had a little
sister so uh to see that kind of style
um already be resembling is really cool
um I have two obviously two little
sisters so um but it's cool I mean till
is till is beautiful man man so so walk
me through man I don't have any kids but
first week home with Titus or first week
home with teal like who was who's up
crying more who's who's the more chill
baby like it's crazy because they're
both similar they like I don't want to
jinx myself but uh they've both been
really good as far as sleeping been not
crying as much maybe I just got super
lucky with that um but no I haven't had
any headaches with my my kids so that's
good man and uh and Titus man he's in
the studio with us today super super
excited man he's uh he's over there
watching on his little iPad and
everything but uh how about how about
this in fact I think I think we got a
clip of uh of Titus man he um he's he's
getting into basketball man how how's
that yeah no it's crazy uh he is he's
just uh he has his little B going in his
house that he uh oh yeah that he he
messes with and um I always bring my
little basketballs around the house too
uh he he tries to take it and and uh and
run around and throw it to my dogs with
it too so it it's cool cuz he knows what
a basketball is and what a hoop is but
he he can't do anything right now with
it but uh eventually I I know he will be
so it's really cool to see man fut
future point guard man and the fist
bumps are are hilarious man but oh yeah
he'll give anybody high five fist bump
and will will not leave until he gives
everyone a fist bump oh yeah no that's
that's his mom teaching him that yeah
for sure so um we can we can jump right
into it man I think uh I think one of
the most exciting things over the
weekend was the um the n Season
tournament um congratulations to the
Lakers but I think it's been interesting
to see the reactions that you guys have
given as in players um overall around
the league um their opinions about the
inseason tournament Kevin Durant even
said um the intensity of these games has
been incredible I wasn't a fan at first
but now I'm a huge fan of the n Season
tournament what what are your thoughts
on the inseason tournament what do you
think now that's now that it's over with
for this year um what were your overall
thoughts I mean I think that it turned
out great for the league I mean having
the the Lakers win it all is is always
going to be great for the league I mean
a lot of people watch the Lakers and
support I mean that's a big brand um so
them winning the first first one is
obviously great for the league and great
for the seon tournament I think it was
great for the whole league I mean in
general just from the competitive aspect
I mean you can tell just a different
intensity level just from those games to
regular season games early on and uh so
you can definitely feel the the
difference and uh I think the the leag
did a great job of like making it a
different feel and different vibe I mean
the courts were different um some were
better than others but uh I think they
they did a good job making a Cool vibe
and making a lot people really
interested in it yeah for sure speaking
of Courts man um I saw Atlanta had that
icy blue Court man that was that was so
nice what were your thoughts on on the
championship Court I know you didn't get
to play on that on that court but it it
was cool I mean it was cool um cool to
watch cool to see I mean I wish we we
could have won on ours but um I mean it
was cool to see like the different
different themes I mean the the
championship Court was clean um but just
there's a lot of really cool courts I
mean Minnesota had a really cool one uh
a couple cool ones that I know we we
played Detroit they had a cool one too
speaking of players opinions on on
things too I know uh originally like
during media day and stuff they were
showing showing guys the courts and
there were some pretty funny clips man
what were uh as a player what was it
like I mean I don't know had you ever
played on like a like a purple court
before or a blue court and like did that
have anything to do with your game like
did you feel like your depth perception
was off like nah nah you don't really it
don't really make no difference I mean
it's it's it's cool for the fan from the
fan aspect but like once you get cuz
you're on the court a little bit before
warming up and stuff and once you can
see where the lines are and you can kind
of really tell anyways cu the seats and
the way the arena is set up so um but no
it's not really too much of a difference
it's it's really more from the the
visual from the fan aspect and um which
makes it cool for the players too
because you get cool jerseys and cool
things like that to match it so uh I
mean it Works hand in hand so in other
words if if you can hoop you can hoop it
it don't matter yeah that's
basic but if you can't hoop like it
doesn't doesn't also doesn't help you
either yeah it don't it don't make no
difference um so the uh it was
interesting it was it was pretty public
that the Pacers actually had the lowest
payroll in the league and then making to
the finals um they they got incredible
Financial incentives of like just just
making it that way and talk about that I
you can talk about whether it was the
opinions in the Hawks locker room or
just overall talking with your peers in
the league but that was like that was
real money that was on the line for the
n Season tournament as in um you know
some incentive to get you guys going and
stuff what was uh what were your initial
thoughts on that and how do you think
those potentially changed um as the
season kind of went on uh no I think I
mean that was good I mean they added
prize money for the for the uh the End
season tournament like I think that was
was what was going to really draw a lot
of teams and making them fully Buy in um
cuz it's not just I mean cuz you you
heard from from LeBron talk about it
like I mean it's not just about the the
high guys who make a lot of money it's
about really now you're competing with
your brothers even more now you got the
bench maybe even more involved and can I
mean engaged in the game and things like
that because they know if they win they
get they get to eat too so I think it
really engages more of a team aspect too
in that in that way so it can be a
positive like that um I don't I don't
see really any any cons when it comes to
the prize money so I think that's I mean
really good for the league and what they
did uh is 500 enough 500,000 or you
think it needs to be more if you win nah
I mean
500 500 is a lot of money it's a lot of
money yeah 500 is a lot of money so I
mean you seen if I mean if if Brun can
go out there and play play hard and do
all that for 500 I mean what what other
player can't so uh that's that's kind of
what it is absolutely so I
know throughout there there was some
debate whenever kind of the wild card
and knockout stages were starting about
the point differential like there were
there were a couple teams that were like
in The Fringe you know kind of in the
hunt for making it to the to The
Knockout run and stuff what were your
thoughts on the point differential and
going into next year would there be any
recommendations that you would have to
potentially change that um to be honest
I wasn't super well versed on it like it
was a little confusing to me I know
there are some some leagues in Europe
that kind of have the same thing when it
comes to like champions league and stuff
like that but um yeah talk talk to that
thought thought process uh no I
mean I think it's part of it I mean it's
I don't think it's you should feel one
way about it I mean the other I think
it's part of it like I I I know some
guys get
mad um me personally I wouldn't have
gotten mad I think it's just part of it
it's part of the game like it's a
different criteria for a different
circumstance like it's not like a
regular game and if you getting your
head beat in like sometimes you got to
take it I mean like you know what I'm
saying like it's I think that's that's
just part of the game like
um so I to be honest with you I'm not
really mad about it I don't really get
offended um seeing it I mean if it was
happening to us I think the Cavs were
trying to do it to us I mean I didn't
feel I didn't feel a certain way about
it I think they were trying to get in
and um we were already out and they were
just trying to trying to get in so I
don't I don't think it's any disrespect
I think it's a different different
circumstance and a different criteria
what was was needed in certain certain
games Trey I don't know if you saw but
there was this uh this clip that that
was kind of going viral a little bit um
I came in in the green room and I told
Kenny I said Kenny Trey is the real deal
question you remind me of tyres I mean
Tyreek excuse me you remind me of Ernie
it ain't me it's a damn cannabis behind
me yeah no that's hilarious bro shout
out Shaq man shout out Shaq the the the
Cannabis reference behind him for for a
for a misspeak is is great that's just
that's just that's just part of it I
mean he just you forgot I mean that
ain't no shade towards Tyrese he's AER
all at all I I totally agree I think um
I I I took that as a as a compliment to
you to be honest is like you y'all both
are balling at this point yeah I mean we
we both ERS I mean just cuz he's there
and I'm not don't mean people ain't
thinking about me now that the inseason
tournament is kind of wrapped up um what
were your overall thoughts I know we saw
some some players emerge speaking of
Tyrese had a hell of inseason tournament
um it's been playing really well this
season but any surprises to you
throughout the n Season tournament man I
mean obviously there's no there's not
like it's like an NCA tournament type of
a Vibe like it was really one I mean
taking it one game at a time and uh
whoever gets hot can win it all and I
mean the Pacers went on a hell of a run
Tyrese was balling um scoring getting
everybody involved I mean it was crazy
to see uh buddy was killing for him
Miles Turner uh they had a lot of guys
who play well Aaron I mean net Smith uh
play the way he played defense on on
Giannis and uh even Braun and certain on
certain moments those those last couple
games was was crazy to see so I mean the
Pacers obviously made made a name for
themselves and and uh gave themselves a
little bit of feel of what of um I mean
a playoff environment would be like
especially those games versus the
Celtics and the the bucks um but really
the Celtics so I think it was just a
good good experience a lot of a lot of
teams can learn from things we can learn
from things and next year I'm sure Adam
Silver will add some new things that'll
make it even more cool and uh it'll get
even better next year yeah pivoting to
the Lakers like I said congratulations
to them but how do you you think that
expectations now that they've won the
East n Season tournament have changed
now that you know they're we're going
into All-Star break soon uh and you know
going into the playoffs do you think
that winning that inseason tournament
gives them a different type of pressure
or um I mean maybe from the outside
looking in I think I think anytime you
play for the Lakers you going to have
pressure on you uh just in general so I
don't think they necessarily feel that
when you you win a an inseason
tournament that I mean they G have more
pressure on them I think they already
feel that they have pressure on them
every night they play and um that's how
you should feel if you play for that
organization so um I don't know how they
feel um I know as a competitor playing
against them I I think we still look at
them like like they're the Lakers and we
just got to I mean when we play them we
it's like another game we got to we got
to play in we know it's a different
environment in there and whenever they
come there to your place it's a
different environment so um but there's
still the Lakers though yeah man
speaking of speaking of the y'all's
place and all that I think it's a great
way to transition to the hawk season um
we haven't recorded since uh since you
guys started so um overall man I know I
know you guys are are just getting
started but H how you feel about the
season so far and what you guys are
building and out there in Atlanta yeah I
mean I feel like we we've got off to an
okay start um it it was tough after
really Jaylen went down um I don't know
what I was whenever um before he went
down but I know we've we haven't really
won too many games since he's been out
and uh he's a big piece that we're
missing um we're already uh I mean a
kind of um young team not very
experienced team um after a couple guys
but uh and Jaylen was playing like the
most improved player for us and not only
us but just killing the whole league
every every night he played so having
him out I mean kind of hurts us and in a
couple ways and um but I think we're
still learning we still have a long
season to go um we' started off worse um
I've been in in worse circumstances and
and finished great so uh it's really
about just finding um a
good streak of wins and finding a place
where we can we can build off some wins
and and learn off some wins and also
getting some guys healthy and getting
them back and then I feel like we'll be
good yeah speaking of Jaylen Johnson I
think he uh like you said definitely a
candidate for most improved what have
you been most surprised about with his
progression from last year to this year
and then what are you looking forward to
him providing you guys' you guys' group
and and ball club uh I mean there's a
there's a lot I mean jaylen's done
different I mean but for me I think from
what I see is his confidence and
obviously your confidence always grows
as you as you play more and you get more
minutes and more experience and so
he's obviously getting a lot more of
that this year and you're seeing the
confidence grow every game that he plays
but just from shooting the ball um when
he gets the ball pushing it um he
doesn't make too many mistakes um and
that's something that's really good uh
so I just love playing with a guy that's
that's smart um but he still has a lot
of a lot of room to grow and he knows
that and he's so um open died and wide
ear that he he's he's willing to listen
to people around him that that's going
to help him get better too so he
definitely has has a bright future I
know we're early on in the season but
with Jaylen Johnson A Healthy Hawks team
where do you where do you think you guys
pin out in the East this year uh I mean
we we have a chance I mean the last two
years has been been some crazy crazy
runs in the in the East I mean teams
going to the championship as eight seeds
and um it's it's all about just being
hot at the right moment so like it's
hard to really
judge where where we'll be but I I feel
like our potential we can beat anybody
um if we're fully healthy and we're
we're at the right mindset and we're
clicking on all cylinders yeah yeah
y'all can definitely beat beat anybody
especially if you dropping people uh
like you like you did in this clip oh
yeah y'all y'all Bea anybody if y'all do
that yeah yeah that was that was a crazy
O's reaction Oh's reaction don't want to
look at it they got they got the win
DeAnthony got the last last laugh that
was definitely a a nice nice play for
sure I uh I haven't done anybody like
that before dropping somebody like that
what's it like to drop somebody like
that man bro it's it's just like
a it's like a I don't know a feeling man
it's like you know it's like no I do not
know don't do that cuz that's that's not
that's not truthful at all it's like um
I don't know it's just a it's just a
feeling you have and it's like an
adrenaline Russian why why would you why
would you why would you say you like you
know that seemed like a no cuz I'm sure
like you probably had like a little
cousin or somebody you was messing
around with and oh okay I thought you
were you were implying that you dropped
me before and I was about to say no I
definitely have though you no what what
clip exactly no I think I think we can
we can find a clip every putting it on
the record that Trey young has never
NE v r drop
me Dr you or are you in a clip no not in
a clip neither okay wow not in the clip
neither do you have it on your phone by
any chance no okay I switch phones but I
can find this clip though I'm glad I'm
glad you made the shot though because um
I think I think this year in particular
there's been an offensive explosion
around the league teams have become
incredibly efficient in their offense
there are four teams right now that are
averaging higher than 120 points you
guys the Atlanta Hawks Indiana Pacers
Milwaukee Bucks and uh the
76ers um who do you think has there been
uh has there been a certain person in
the league that has kind of helped drive
that offensive explosion this year um
whether it be current guys or whether it
be um guys who have just you know helped
change the game just in general
um and and why do you think that this
year in particular the the offenseive
around the league has not only been
incredibly efficient but also scoring a
lot a lot of
points I mean it's I think it's a a lot
of different cases I mean a lot of
different reasons that I mean teams are
scoring out a high clip I think first
reason the the Warriors and what they've
done since they're the start of their
Dynasty and they really had the best
offense for a lot of years and won a lot
of
championships um and then you got like
nowadays you got last year you got the
Sacramento Kings I think breaking a
record and having points per game um and
just their offense and how Firepower
they were uh and then like you just have
a lot of young guards that come in just
ready to play like ever since really my
draft with me and Luca like ever since
then it's like guards coming out every
year it's like ready to to go from day
one or um or or put put on the go from
day one it's like I mean guards are
ready and then you got the
Pacers I mean their coach two of their
coaches coached coach me and Luca I mean
in our offenses have always been great
so it's like offenses in the game is I
mean it's perennial like you need to
have really good offense but the best
teams have both like the best teams have
really good offenses and a really good
defense and I think that's what makes
the difference between a great team and
just an okay team yeah and what would
you say to the critics that say that
this offensive explosion in the NBA is
due to a lack of
defense and they just that's
just that's just that's lame that's lame
excuse I think that's just
because the the talent level is so crazy
like the what guys are what guys are
capable of doing and just the cerebral
ability of some of these guys that also
have talent and god-given length and and
I mean size on them like it's it's it's
tough to guard these guys when they're
smart I mean with the talent that
they're given so I think the the talent
today is is also a reason why the
offenses are so high and scoring so high
yeah I agree I think that like you said
lame I think lazy is probably another
word in that I
think I think that saying that the
offensive explosion is due to lack of
Defense actually isn't G giving
offensive schemes offensive players
enough credit that they actually do I
mean you've seen gold golden state for
example if you just watch some of their
possessions like they'll track the way
Steph runs around and he's running you
know couple hundred feet in a single
possession like that's all type of
schemes and for sure and it's and also
like it's hard to for for for a team
like the Pacers or team like us that are
going to
score5 130 points to keep a team to 105
or 10 six a night cuz then you're
beating team by 30 like it may be a we
may not be the number one defense so we
may be 10 to 15 but that's that's better
than being you know 25 to 30 you know
what I'm saying so I think that's that's
where it can get kind of L sided too
because really good offenses you
obviously have more possessions ex that
you're giving the other team too so
they're going to naturally score some
yeah exactly um you know I think uh
you're a natural born score anyways and
um I'd say you have a pretty uh deep bag
deep deep bag of tricks when it comes to
comes to scoring the ball man um I've uh
I've witnessed it for a couple years now
but um I actually have I actually have a
few a few tweets um that we can go
through um and this actually something
new that we're going to be starting on
on from the point um we we encourage all
our audience m MERS to to send in some
tweets comment on our YouTube channel um
use use the BR app to send in some
Tweets we're actually going to be
answering a few few questions each
episode um but I have a couple here um
first up overall who's the funniest
player in the
NBA funniest player in the
NBA to me it's
yic to me is yic really why he's
hilarious like uh just some of the stuff
like you see some of the stuff he does
in his like in his post game in his
interviews or whatever like just being
like like in games with him interacting
little moments and Allstar behind the
see little moments it's like he's so
he's he's funny can you imitate one of
his uh his reactions you can't you can't
imitate it I remember being in charlet
one year I think he did we did the
skills skills challenge together and we
were just in the the back and and he was
just making everybody laugh like it was
he's just hilarious he he is hilarious
though his uh his game is great but man
that that dud is a comedian for sure
folks say you still don't play defense
though uh somebody actually wrote in and
said um folks still saying Trey young
doesn't play defense uh right here you
can see uh you actually have a game
saving charge yeah to to win the Spurs
game yeah what's your thoughts on uh not
playing defense I mean this I mean you
can't say that this year it's been my
best year playing uh defense I mean I
mean that's that's I mean just a fact um
you can hate all you want I mean that's
that's just what it is I've I mean
taking charges uh being there for my
teammates obviously we can we can all be
better I can be better on that end still
we haven't won enough games for me to
say I'm uh first team or anything but
definitely getting better uh but
definitely definitely been a thing on my
mind and what do you think moving
forward has allowed you to not only
continue to get better at defense but as
you guys go throughout the season not
only for you to continue to be solid
defensively but your entire team to
continue to improve I think my coach
helps me a lot and just putting me in
spots and places and just telling me
where to be before um I'm putting spots
where I can't really help myself I mean
I'm already at like a a disadvantage um
in a lot of ways so just being knowing
where to be early before the the offense
gets theirs is important too so my coach
helps me a lot with that for sure um as
of today uh what's the biggest NBA
rivalry in the
NBA today what's the biggest NBA
rivalry
um you go first because I have my own
take on this okay you go first because I
I'll need a second I would say based off
of last
year it's probably not the biggest but I
think it's one of the most exciting
rivalries is King's Warriors I think it
would be I think it would be great to
see another playoff series like that um
I think at every position on the court
they have a great
matchup at all times so I think that uh
I think the Kings Warriors is a is a is
a good one I think there are some more
King Warriors I think
um yeah that's that's a good one I mean
Fox and yeah that's good Kings
Warriors man I I don't really you don't
see really teams hating each other like
that I mean you
see Steph and that that Warriors and
Kings being that but I don't know I
don't know either that or ain't no
really rivalry no more why do you think
it's not like it used to be in terms of
like
rivalries it's because these refs don't
let nobody show emotion and as far as
just like you can't say nothing to
nobody as far it's not even it ain't
even got to be egregious or
nothing it's it can be dunking on
somebody and just giving them a look
like it's a tech like that is the
craziest thing to me like just from
growing up watching guys you guys used
to be able to dunk and yell like it's
different it's different like that's how
you build rivalries when you talking you
getting scored on and you like going
back and forth and then
it's different if guys's getting face to
face then you can call a tech and break
them up but guys's just talking like
even my first couple years in the league
it was different than how it is now like
it's just it's it's crazy I think the
rest don't allow it us to have really
NBA robberies anymore for real that's
fair I think that's a that's a fair take
yeah um who do you think is the most
explosive athlete in NBA history oh most
explosive athlete in NBA
history uh there's a lot
um dang most
explosive I mean the first one that
comes to mind is
Russ I mean just from what I mean
explosive like just off the off the Run
dribble like off one off two D Rose
could jump off two I didn't necessarily
see him jump off one all the time but D
Rose they come to mind
like I don't know them two probably
probably Russ I remember being at
Oklahoma City games when we were growing
up together and man Russ would get going
on the break man and it was oh it was
over with
you it was over with it was over with
yeah I think uh like you said D Rose uh
throw LeBron in there Vince Carter Vince
VC VC was explosive VC those those are
of couple I've remember seeing VC in
practice he's 40 years old like
windmilling bro windmill like it was the
lightest windmill I've ever seen like I
thought he was ridiculous so maybe him
too but Russ as far as what I was seeing
Vision Trey what's your opinion on what
if Trey young never got hurt in game
three of the 2021 Eastern Conference
Finals
man that's a great
question what if I mean to be honest
with you I ain't going going to lie yeah
you got we definitely would have we
would have won our first CHP that year
for
sure I don't even want to talk about it
because it's so hard to get back to that
moment it's
like you just you just fight that
feeling that you you had your chance but
I know we going to have another one um
so yeah that's been my biggest goal is
just to give bring Atlanta their
first their first ring so that's going
to happen again but again getting hurt
was not the best feeling cuz I
definitely felt like we had a chance and
we were on a run and we were feeling
good um guys were guys were going
and that that [__] happened and people
don't understand uh how difficult it is
to to make it that far on the playoffs
how how difficult is it actually to make
it that far on the
playoffs just think about it like we had
to we had to play we were the fif seed
so we had to play the fourth seed on the
road to start it
out went five games second round we
played Philly who was the number one
seed at the time we had to go to their
place first and that ended up going
seven games so we won at their place at
seven and then just to that's just to
get to the Conference Finals like and
then now we playing the Bucks who were I
think the second seat at the time and we
ended up going six and just fell short
but that just knows how hard it is you
give respect to the guys who who do it
over and over again or um just get there
and uh so yeah you don't necessarily
throw shade at the guys who necessarily
can't and because there's a lot of guys
who are still playing who are I mean get
a lot of love and a lot of Praise who
don't necessarily get to even the
Conference Finals so um you don't
necessarily throw shade on them when
they don't as a player who's been there
um I'm not speaking for the general fans
but just as a player who's been there
you don't necessar throw shade on those
guys because you understand how hard it
is but uh it definitely sucks cuz I
definitely feel we had a chance for sure
man first episode in the books with
Bleacher Report man how you feel man
feel feel
amazing um feel great I think I think
that wraps us up man well first episode
Bleacher Report another episode of from
the point by your favorite Point till
next time
we'll see yall make you can you're going
to be able to find from the point on
Bleacher Report all season long make
sure you tune in on the BR app and uh
yeah peace
peace